largest climate protest yet at this
week's united nations climate talks is
taking place in glasgow scotland
it's the latest of a series of rallies
as world leaders meet at what's known as
cop 26.
roxanna siberia is in glasgow where
activists are calling on countries to
cut fossil fuels and greenhouse gas
emissions
roxanna good morning
[Music]
good morning jeff protesters are just
starting to gather here despite the rain
they want their calls for more action on
climate change to be held by world
leaders who are meeting just a few
blocks away tens of thousands of
protesters are expected to march here in
glasgow today even more than yesterday
when many young people hit the streets
many tell us they've already been living
with the disastrous effects of climate
change whether it's droughts wildfires
or smog in the past week at cop26
several governments have pledged to curb
deforestation and carbon and methane
emissions but many protesters say
they've seen similar promises broken
before and that countries and companies
must do more faster to protect the world
they're inheriting we asked john kerry
who's at the talks negotiating on behalf
of president biden what message he has
for them
i respect their worry completely and
they have every reason in the world to
be angry
and frustrated i'm frustrated i have my
own reservations about some
promises that get made but but what is
happening here is different
this is a different cup
and i sense a much greater sense of
urgency from companies from ngos
everybody involved here understands this
for real and we've got to get this done
swedish climate activist greta tunberg
who has inspired a lot of young people
to protest has called this summit a pr
exercise she's expected to speak at the
rally later today also today more than
200 events just like this one are set to
take place around the world michelle
and they seem ready for action thank you
roxanna